have you met volcanium he's Pokemon  number 721 and he's the first of his  kind not the first one to look like a  life preserver he's the first fire /  water type volcanium is called a steam  Pokemon which totally makes sense given  fire plus water that weird thing on his  back is used to eject the steam from his  body the official description says that  move is powerful enough to blow away an  entire mountain so volcania isn't  someone to mess with most legendary  Pokemon art while camion is set to  appear in the most recent Pokemon games  alpha sapphire and Omega Ruby but you  can't get him just yet the trailer says  more details are coming soon so you'll  have to sit tight until Nintendo  releases more info into the wild in the  meantime you can check gamespot com for  the latest on all things Pokemon I'm  Tony and i'll see you on Victory Road